well welcome back time for the fastest
first off forget about weed how about
some mindbending magic mushrooms
thousands of folks in Oregon are on a
waight list for the state's very first
licensed Silo cbin facility sounds like
they're absolutely itching to go on a
psychedelic Journey well I thought we'd
start with our magic mushroom most
likely suspect
Shannon her magic mushroom is Jesus have
you or have you ever not taken magic
mushroom I take the fifth as an attorney
the thing that I love about this first
of all if you've seen the streets of
Portland what they definitely need is
more people on mind altering drugs
although you don't have to have a
prescription for this but apparently you
do have to go sit with somebody who's a
licensed person who kind of gets you
through the Journey think about that job
I mean you could get serious blackmail
on people if you're sitting there
watching them and you have to stay with
them the whole time until they come back
down well Greg apparently for roughly
six hours adults over 21 can experience
what many users describe as Vivid
geometric shapes a loss of identity and
a oness with the universe very much like
doing the GF show right well I I mean i'
I've done them regularly and and so
I joking what you're not joking no I'm
not joking going to don't arrest them
we're getting information it's still a
cbin it's probably it's it's being used
in PTSD for veterans unlike Other Drug
under other drugs it's medicinal and not
recreational this is why you sit and you
have somebody there you're not going out
and partying on them would people were
younger they did but what what what
psilocybin does when you take it and you
did mention the what what goes on it's
trying to show you the user interface
between your subjective reality what you
believe that you are seeing and what is
really out there so so a good a good
analogy which is what a lot of the
researchers use is when you look on your
laptop screen and you see the icons on
your screen like the little garbage can
and you drag something into the garbage
can it's not really a garbage can it's
simply representative of that what psoy
and shows you is what is behind each
icon that you see in the world hence the
geometric images the the the patterns of
light and everything when you take
psilocybin you literally see what is
behind everything it pulls the curtain
back it changes your life you realize
you realize there's something greater
out there atheists when they take
psilocybin they're on they're they're no
longer atheist so I'm telling you it is
actually a spir it actually is a
spiritual thing so it's sort of a come
to J it come to Jesus if he's your
dealer no but is it ever scary it can be
if you take the wrong dois which is why
you do it with somebody who's done it
and is a regular professional that's why
this is a good thing and who knows
Portland this might be the if it gets
them off the opiates and the and all the
other stuff it might work but I all
right well judge uh it remain it remains
silos cin remains illegal in most of the
United States but it has been described
by the Food and Drug Administration as a
breakthrough therapy so where do you sit
with well first of all I'm not not a fan
of the FDA I mean you know I used Puda
fed for years and found out it really
wasn't working look it's a good thing
that that Oregon has a priorities in
order you know what just what they need
more drugs in 2020 they passed the law
and they said we're going to
decriminalize hard drugs me and LSD and
cocaine and heroin and uh so now they're
under pressure to change the fact that
they decriminalize it because there's so
much crime going on uh along with the
drug use look Greg I don't have your
experience with drug so I can't speak to
it my only experience was locking people
up who use these drugs so um you know no
one arrests people on mushrooms yeah the
here's the thing I think the potency now
is different I think people are buying
stuff off the street I think fentanyl is
now a part of the equation I liked it
may be in a comined space with an expert
I like that but you know what I don't
see a happy ending they do it with XT
they do it with MDMA they're doing it
with psilocybin it is the reality you
are not going to get rid of this okay
well he says you got to do it with
someone who knows what they're talking
about I think we've established who the
world expert is at this test Jesse wers
are you going to go on a magic you
mushroom you did it you call them a
sherpa they're going to be your little
guide for the trip
exactly I knew
it the daming Silence of Jesse Waters
judge it's you and me so I was at the
Almond Brothers concert one time and at
the Beacon and and what they do during
the show they'll throw out like a whole
sack of shrooms and he launched it to
the second level and I was only 18 I
couldn't afford good seats so it lands
like right next to me so I go over like
this to grab it and I grab it and then
right as someone else they grabbed it
like this and then so we were fighting
over the bag of shrooms together it was
like a t-shirt wrapped in some rubber
band and then all of a sudden I was like
I need to I went and I yanked it and I
ended up elbowing an usher and the Usher
grabs me and then pulls me away and I
said no
did you get any inside you I got
nothing beautiful hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else